how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and today we are talking about
spider-man 3 because it seems like we
may know who
the villains are and on top of that we
have some news about charlie cox who of
course played daredevil
in the netflix series being in
spider-man 3 a little bit of toby
maguire news and some leaked set photos
as well
so to start this video off let's talk
about charlie cox's daredevil
wrapping filming for spider-man 3
meaning he's already filmed his part
whatever that is going to be for the
movie
this report is coming from comicbook.com
who said they spotted him on set a while
ago he's been spotted on set again
recently and now they're reporting that
they have learned charlie cox has
actually finished
filming all of his parts for spider-man
homecoming 3.
now we know that charlie cox is going to
be playing matt murdock that's who he
played in the netflix daredevil series
but we're not sure if he's actually
going to be playing the same
matt murdock it's the same actor but is
it the same character
from the netflix series another thing
that comicbook.com said is they actually
don't know if daredevil will be
appearing they know that matt murdock
will be appearing but they're not sure
about daredevil now giving the ending of
spider-man far from home
it's safe to say that peter is going to
need a lawyer which of course
matt murdock is so this could be how we
get matt murdock
in the marvel cinematic universe and his
cameo in spider-man 3.
he could be peter's lawyer and again we
don't know about actual
daredevil appearing but based off of
some recent reports
spider-man's going to need his help now
we already know that some old villains
are going to be returning for spider-man
3 such as
dr octopus electro and the sandman
now these are all from different
universes but there are rumors going
around right now that we are going to
see the original
sinister six in spider-man 3. dr octopus
electro
and sandman are all a part of the
original sinister six
and the other three interestingly enough
are vulture
mysterio and craven the hunter now
vulture is already there michael
keaton's character adrian toombs already
exists within the mcu
and also apparently in the sony pictures
universe of marvel characters as well
but vulture is already there in the
marvel cinematic universe so it won't be
hard to recruit him
for a sinister six team then we have
mysterio who of course exists within the
mcu he was the main villain in
spider-man far from home
but many believe him to be dead i
however do not
i don't think that the master of
illusions really died at the end of far
from home
i think there's a really good chance
that he could be alive which means he
could be a part of the sinister six in
spider-man 3.
and then we have craven the hunter now
craven the hunter is said to be the
original
sole villain of spider-man 3. this was
before the idea of
the multiverse and spider-verse came in
in fact at one point in time it was
reported that sony and
marvel were looking for a joel kinnaman
type of actor to play the role of craven
the hunter
well even though it doesn't look like
he's going to be the sole main villain
of spider-man 3 he is going to be a
villain
as part of the sinister six if these
rumors end up being true which it would
make sense that we're going to have
many villains with the rumors that toby
maguire's spider-man
and andrew garfield spider-man are going
to be returning now moving on to that
topic the topic of toby mcguire
spider-man it was reported a couple of
weeks ago that andrew garfield and toby
mcguire were on set
filming for spider-man 3. well that
might not be
the entire case as of right now because
toby maguire was just spotted
in la he was out for a hike with a
friend and the paparazzi snagged a photo
of him
now this photo is copyrighted by
justjared.com so i can't show it but
he is in la right now now could he have
been filming and gone back
sure it's not hard for him to take a
private jet or charter a jet and fly
back home and then fly back to atlanta
to film
in fact that may be what the studio
wants him to do in order to
kind of throw everybody off but right
now it's a little unclear if toby has
already started filming for spider-man 3
or if he hasn't yet but we'll have to
wait and see
and last but not least we do have some
leaked set photos from the set
of spider-man homecoming 3 which
seemingly confirmed that spider-man 3
will at least
in part be somewhat of a christmas movie
or at least shot during the christmas
period
we have some leaked set photos of a
donut and pastry shop
labeled peter pan donut and pastry shop
now what's interesting
is this is an actual pastry shop in
brooklyn new york the design of the shop
is a little bit different in real life
but the name
how it is is exactly the same so they're
recreating in atlanta
a brooklyn donut and pastry shop and as
you can see from the photo it says
merry christmas on one of the windows
and has hot chocolate on the other along
with other christmas decorations
so spider-man 3 at some point is going
to be during the christmas period
and this makes sense if they're going to
try and make it a little bit emotional
christmas is a time where you usually
spend with your family
but if peter is on the run and he can't
be with his family or his friends
that could add to a lot of emotionality
for him in this movie
and those are our spider-man 3 updates
for today be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
spider-man 3 news
and of course other marvel news as well
be sure to let me know what you think
about all these recent reports do you
think
daredevil is going to show up or do you
think it's just going to be matt murdock
and how excited would you be if
spider-man
fought the original sinister six let me
know in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof